just when you think president biden has
reached rock bottom
a trap door seems to open up in the rock
and send him careening even further down
biden's approval rating has officially
reached the lowest point of his
presidency it's a dismal 30 percent and
his disapproval rating is all the way up
at 58 percent biden is underwater in 48
states including california new york
even his home state of delaware the only
two states in which biden is even
treading water are hawaii and vermont
and even there the numbers are pretty
weak
in addition to being underwater in
general throughout almost the entire
country biden is also underwater on
virtually every issue
he's got a net negative approval rating
on race guns the environment crime
ukraine and abortion
the only issue that he's even slightly
above water on is covid so expect
another round of that to drop any day
now and even there even on kovid he's
only net positive by two points
but most people don't vote on
kovid
most people don't vote on abortion most
people don't vote on ukraine
most people vote on issues that are more
tangible and more visible such as
the economy and even cnn even lib state
media is admitting that the economy is
in shambles
where do we stand right now with
inflation well i think for a lot of
americans their reality is being shaped
by the really high inflation let's take
a look at cpi consumer inflation you'd
have to go back to the early 80s to see
the type of levels we're seeing the last
cpi report came in at about eight point
six percent of course we know under the
hood of that number it's really high
energy prices really high food prices uh
the cost of new and used cars have gone
up pretty much everything broad-based
has gone up the cost of shelter has gone
up which has some economists really
concerned so i think if you are an
american at home it's really hard
perhaps understandably to feel great
about the economy right now even though
there are some silver linings when
you're getting hit so hard with
inflation even personally anna you know
i talk to economists and traders and
analysts every day about this and
sometimes i find myself shocked when i
go to the grocery store and look at
prices and think wow this costs this now
and so it's it's understandable
even the chiron on the screen it says 88
say us is on the wrong track that's cnn
cnn is changing its tune because no
matter how left-wing the people who run
the network are they want to make money
and hold on to the handful of viewers
that they have left they don't want to
go down with joe biden who despite
consistent failure refuses to change
course
there's a line from ronald reagan that
is overused but it's apt here in the
face of such stubborn intractable
failure from the white house
a recession is when your neighbor loses
his job a depression is when you lose
your job and recovery is when joe biden
loses his job i'm michael knowles that's
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from pathfinder who
says watching libs fight with each other
is like watching biden on stairs
one you know you're in for a show
two it's never their fault three nothing
will make sense that's very mean that's
very mean and evocative and accurate and
precise that's the way it goes
lest anyone accuse us of being too tough
on mr biden today i've invited on my
friend a true a card-carrying democrat
ethan bearman very well-known democrat
lawyer you've seen him on fox news and
lots of tv shows
ethan thank you for coming on
michael look it's uh if we weren't
friends i wouldn't be here but here we
are and um
i always appreciate you inviting me on i
mean that so it's good to see you today
and i'm glad you're doing well well
thank you for coming on i
this is not even a debate this one
sometimes we do these debate kind of
segments this is not even a debate this
is me in all sincerity and all sweet
little innocence
one is there still an argument that
democrats can be making for joe biden
whether we're talking about joe biden as
the nominee in 2024 whether we're
talking about joe biden campaigning for
dems in 2022 whether we're talking about
the job joe biden is doing is there an
argument that democrats can still be
making for joe biden and if there is
what is it
yeah i mean that i appreciate you asking
the question and i think that there's a
very strong one first if you ignore the
endless 24-hour drum beat since the day
he was elected from right-wing media
which only speaks negatively of him
let's be clear he passed the
infrastructure bill 1.2 trillion dollars
got that done that the previous
president kept talking about for four
years joe biden got that done he got the
burn pit act passed he actually takes
care of our military veterans the
largest expansion of va benefits in over
a generation we have the lowest
unemployment rate so if you're going to
use that reagan quote people aren't
losing their jobs right now for the most
part of course there's always limited
segments of the economy losing their
jobs 3.6 unemployment rate lower than
the pre previous president's lowest
unemployment rate let's add a really
huge one into that as well
we had
russia invade an independent
sovereign nation who is an ally we
signed a 1994 treaty with called ukraine
and
biden
pulled together the largest coalition in
the west
since world war ii
to defend in europe to defend against
this invasion to send arms to train
to send aid we have been
helping our ukrainian friends i don't
even think we've been helping enough but
that's my own personal opinion yeah
there are huge things in biden's favor
by the way you missed one key poll
in your citation there mr knowles which
goal is that there was just a poll done
head-to-head joe biden against ron
desantis joe biden against donald trump
gavin newsom who i know you particularly
love to pick on news
desantis and trump and they both beat
trump and desantis
so
despite the approval rating polls
despite the issues polls you're saying
look once they go up against these
republicans especially that dirty rotten
trump but desantis also though there
have been polls like that new hampshire
poll that came out a couple of weeks ago
that puts desantis ahead of joe biden
but you say look you go up against the
real republicans the democrats are going
to win i must have pushed back a little
bit on ukraine
let's not forget that uh mr zielinski
the president of ukraine did say that
the immediate cause of the war in
ukraine was the easing of sanctions
western specifically american sanctions
against russia and the green lighting of
the nordstrom 2 oil pipeline those are
zolensky's words not mine that was
something that joe biden did he then
not only
figuratively or
sort of
in a modest indirect way invited putin
to invade ukraine but then when he was
asked will you react if putin invades
ukraine he said that if it were only a
minor incursion he wouldn't do very much
which seems to me to be a direct
invitation regardless of all that yes
biden now is uh governing after the
coronavirus lockdowns though he did push
for some more restrictive measures he's
still they're reopening the economy
unemployment is low sure but surely you
have to admit ethan the economy it's not
it's not going well we've got record
high inflation we've got uh record high
gas prices record high food prices right
it's not going well right
so
the economy is exceptionally complex so
if we want to discuss certain key data
points look i was the one that went on
fox news last summer as a democrat and
said
biden is wrong
and his administration i should say was
wrong to say that inflation was just
transitory and it didn't really mean
much so i absolutely agree that
inflation is a very serious
direct issue to individual americans and
to the economy as a whole there is
absolutely no denying that and anybody
who does i believe is either just a pure
partisan hack or a liar um and so i
never
will espouse that statement so i agree
with you that the inflation is i but
however somebody who works with
businesses across many sectors as i have
i also worked in the supply chain
during the epidemic trying to get
products from china as an attorney
helping people and i'm going to just
tell you something the pandemic
dramatically and right now china still
has lockdowns going on and if the
overwhelming majority of our products
are still coming from china by the way
manufacturing
facility construction under joe biden in
the united states is up 116
percent so that's another victory for
joe biden that you haven't mentioned
we're bringing manufacturing back under
joe biden the keratin stick approach has
worked and it was trump who put the
tariffs on chinese products which
directly are paid for by the u.s
consumer so the pandemic altered the
global supply chain the uk has higher
inflation countries around the world
have higher inflation canada has higher
inflation than the united states right
now it's not a joe biden issue it's a
global issue and joe biden has done
things to help the supply chain in the
united states by incentivizing
manufacturing companies as i just
mentioned manufacturing is up in the
united states he's helped the ports here
on the west coast to move the products
through faster he did that last summer
here at the port of long beach and port
of los angeles in particular uh which
are the major gateways for for the east
asian products of which americans
continue to buy so from that perspective
joe biden has actually done a very good
job inflation and corporate profits are
at record highs remember corporate
profits
according to the wall street journal not
a left-leaning publication are the
highest they have been since the early
1960s so
surely ethan you would have to admit
when we're talking about inflation you
can't have that conversation without
energy prices it would seem pretty clear
to me joe biden has opposed the
expansion of the most reliable sources
of american energy he shut down the oil
pipelines he shut down new oil and gas
leases in the united states are you
saying there's there's no effect here
are you saying that had biden not had a
more open energy policy and instead of
green lighting pipelines for russia he
greenlit some pipelines in the united
states instead of shaking down iran for
oil he produced oil in the united states
you don't think that would have any
effect i guess we're out of time but i
on that point i i would ask this
additional question
which is
if everything's going so well for joe
biden why are democrats looking so bad
historically bad in the generic midterm
polls why why are the republicans
looking at picking up potentially 40 to
60 seats in the house according to not
just the right wing polls but the
left-wing polls as well if things are
going so well for biden why do the
people seem to be looking for two
republicans in 2022
well midterms first term midterms are
historically bad they were for trump as
well after holding all three uh houses
in the there are two houses in the
executive branch that is a common
problem and again if we get a 24-hour
dump drum beat from most outlets
including social media remember top
posts on facebook are right-wing posts
from your pal in particular here at the
daily wire sure look we do but i have to
correct this a little bit i mean you're
right we do extremely well on social
media especially on facebook but we're
when you're talking about the daily wire
or dan bongino or a couple of other
people compared to abc nbc cbs cnn msnbc
the new york times was it's not even
close the vast vast majority of social
media posts that get traction are
left-wing there there are just more of
those outlets so i mean if if your
argument ethan is that the media
is overwhelmingly or even
even close to right wing that seems
like a difficult argument to make it
it's not and if you and you actually you
made a statement earlier that said that
the the heads at cnn are so liberal i
actually disagree with you um and i
don't believe that that is an accurate
statement anymore that might have been
an accurate statement a few years ago i
don't believe it is anymore um based on
my own knowledge and experience so we
can have that argument separately and i
thank you for inviting me on michael i i
really do appreciate it i love that we
have this conversation ethan you you
have made the strongest argument for joe
biden that i have heard truly you have i
think you've laid out all of the
doesn't exactly persuade me but i do i
very much appreciate
i appreciate you coming on and making it
and we'll see you next time
thanks mike all right thank you ethan
you know when you want to protect your
nest egg in this economy one great place
to look would be birch gold
right now text knolls to 989898
i was wrong about the path inflation
would take i was not wrong i was totally
right but our treasury secretary janet
yellen was wrong and she admitted it
that's a quote from her she said there
have been unanticipated and large shocks
to the economy that have boosted energy
and food prices and supply bottlenecks
that have affected our economy badly
that at the time i didn't fully
understand
didn't fully understand there you have
it
straight from the horse's mouth didn't
fully understand now i know that right
now you're probably worried about
affording basic necessities in the
months to come food gas shelter but hey
she didn't know oopsie daisy not her
fault right goes without saying we
cannot trust these so-called authorities
on economic policy which is why you
should invest at least some of your
money in gold and silver with birch gold
group
these are the guys that i trust you can
protect your savings from a highly
turbulent economy by diversifying your
401k or ira into physical gold text
knowles right now kwles to 989898 get
real advice from birch gold today text
knolls to 989 898 to claim your free no
obligation info kit on protecting your
savings with gold
speaking of
world leaders not doing well right now i
i truly i think ethan made the strongest
arguments you possibly can for joe biden
i don't think they're all that strong
but ethan did a very good job of it i
don't think they're going to work very
well in the midterms which are often bad
for the incumbent party in the white
house but right now our if you look at
the polls are historically bad for the
democrats uh but
but they're making they're making the
best argument they can and they don't
really have a lot of backups for 2024
because kamal is unpopular
pete buda judge is unpopular liz warren
is extremely unpopular liawatha
and so uh it would be uh it would be
difficult to throw biden under the bus
because there's there are very few
people left i i do want to point out on
this show yesterday i didn't even mean
to do this i think i may have killed
boris johnson's political career
yesterday boris johnson the prime
minister of the uk you'll remember i i
analyzed
a clip of him yesterday and i said this
guy he's squishing he's supposed to be
the conservative but he's adopting all
of the liberal language it's so sad the
man had so much promise and he he he was
a strong conservative at first and then
he totally squished well hand me my
nostradamus hat nostradamus hat hand me
my crystal ball because it the news just
broke boris johnson has said he will
step down it's it's very sad the man had
so much promise he was so funny and
right-wing and
but
he squished and when you squish
you lose it's almost inevitable it's not
even that i could predict the future i
just saw what was happening in real time
a real lesson here for american
conservatives do not squish do not try
to suck up to the left-wing media they
are always going to hate you you want to
see the you want to see the real proof
of this right now
is that the left-wing media are going
after not just donald trump but they're
going after ron desantis too here's a
here's a piece from the washington post
desantis is smarter than trump
that may make him
more of a threat
this is by max boot who's a guy who he
kind of came to some mod modest
prominence during the trump years and he
pretended to be this republican who's
turned on the republican party because
of donald trump and now he's now all he
does is support democrats and i said at
the time
during all those debates over never
trump and should republicans support
trump as the nominee
the never trumpers said well this is
unique this is a unique threat to
america we can't support trump he's
especially bad and they maybe they were
sincere but they bought into a lot of
left-wing propaganda and i said don't
believe it guys
yes the line from the left right now is
that trump he's totally different he's
unlike all other republicans we can't
support trump it's okay to be a
republican but you can't support trump
but i said they
they do this
every time they do this to every
republican candidate they're going to do
it to the next republican we're gonna
say oh you know bush look i didn't like
bush but bush was great compared to
trump trump there's no argument any
principal person can't support trump i
said they're gonna do it to the next one
to the next one they're gonna say well
trump was bad and i don't support trump
but you i could understand voting for
trump but you can't possibly vote for
desantis or whoever the next republican
is going to be they they do this every
single time i can't tell you how many
conversations i've had with my very
well-meaning very lovable left-wing
friends and relatives
and they'll come to me they'll concern
troll me they'll come to me on a mission
of mercy to say michael michael listen
you know i love you michael i love you
and look i know you're a republican i'm
not a republican okay i'm no republican
here
but there are republicans and then
there's this guy look i actually i have
some respect
for some republicans
i respect people like george h.w bush
gosh i even i didn't like him but
frankly i'd even sort of have some
respect for george w bush compared to
trump
this guy he's dangerous he's dangerous
you can't any principled serious man
with integrity even if you're a
republican i totally respect republicans
you can't vote for trump that's what
they say and they say it every single
year the formula is
look i'm not a republican
but i respect
insert dead or dying republican
insert i respect republican who is no
longer a political threat who hasn't
been in the news for 20 years okay
and i could frankly even understand
voting for insert the last republican
who they all called hitler when he was
running but now now he's gone so they
don't call him hitler anymore i could
understand voting for him but you you
simply cannot support
insert current republican
they do it to all of them they did it to
reagan they called reagan a nazi and a
white supremacist and a klansman and all
the same stuff they called trump
and then reagan left office and then
they softened a little bit
they went after bush then because bush
ended up losing bush the first they
ended up softening on bush a little more
quickly
then they go after george w bush
remember george w bush was hitler
but then
john mccain was the nominee then john
mccain was hitler compared to bush and
then mitt romney was the nominee and
mitt romney oh he beat up gay kids he's
hitler he's a nazi he's worse he's
actually worse than bush and then mitt
romney goes away and now he sims for the
democrats and so now romney's good and
then
now as trump he's the unique threat and
then it gets to desantis they're going
to do it every single time you need to
stop falling for that
you need to stop falling for that you
need to just support
you need to support the most
conservative viable candidate that you
possibly can because it's not real if
they're going to do it to desantis who
is theoretically everything they should
respect he went to ivy league schools
he's got a personal life that seems
cleaner than most politicians i don't
you don't hear it of any big scandals
coming out of ron desantis
he is
a serious policy wonk he doesn't throw
bombs on twitter
he he's just a he's an effective good
governor
if they're going to go after him they'll
go after anybody so just stop buying it
folks it's so red they do it every
single time they call
larry elder when he's running as the
republican candidate for governor of
california they call him the black face
of white supremacy
do it they do it to everyone you don't
need to believe this stuff okay
they're going to ratchet this up because
despite ethan's best efforts to
say that joe biden could very possibly
win running on the infrastructure bill
or whatever that's probably not going to
be the biggest motivating factor what's
going to motivate people at the polls is
record inflation and the economy and the
crime the fact that our cities are in
shambles the fact that biden is
underwater on virtually every single
issue and so the only option that the
democrats are going to have is to go
negative they have to go negative
because there is very little there's
really nothing positive that they can
point to from their own guy so they're
gonna go negative don't squish don't
throw your own guy under the bus it's a
trap i'm like admiral akbar it's a trap
don't
fall for it
biden right now has managed to blame
everybody biden has he's he says the
economy it's putin's fault no no the
economy it's trump's fault no no the
economy is this guy's fault that guy's
fault now joe biden is blaming
republicans for obstructing his
wonderful super-duper popular agenda
a lot over enough money to pay for
everything you need
well republicans do nothing to obstruct
our efforts to lower your gas taxes i
propose that i've asked the congress to
eliminate the federal gas tax
for the next as long as this crisis goes
on lower food prices lower health care
costs hopefully soon lower your
prescription drug costs
by the way you got a
you got a republican leader in the
united states senate
i was able to work out something with
intel
okay so
biden is very upset
because the republicans
won't
pass his gas tax cut
in the congress
because the republicans control the
congress right oh wait no they don't joe
biden has unified government joe biden
has completely unified government he has
the house of representatives he has the
senate he could pass these things if
they were
if they were popular among democrats if
he weren't
cramming them in to a bunch of other
stupid legislation that has nothing to
do with getting rid of with lowering the
gas tax do you really think that
republicans would oppose lowering the
gas tax
no some democrats might oppose lowering
the gas tax but the republicans won't
you can't blame the republicans for this
kind of obstruction
when you've got unified government man
it you can't do it it's much more
plausible for joe biden to blame putin
for all of his problems and that's
ridiculous too
you just but they're running out of
options so you're going to see this
campaign get way way more negative the
new york times has a peace out right now
on congress congressman myra flores
she is
a latina republican from texas she's
actually from mexico i think she's the
first mexican-born lady to serve in
in the congress
she was the first republican to
represent her district in about a
bazillion years and so of course the
libs are really going after her they say
it's the rise of the far right latina
very far right latina what makes her far
right i don't know i can't find very
much that makes her all that far right
she's a conservative she's not some
fringe person they they haven't managed
to call her a klansman or anything or to
call her a neo-nazi quite yet though i'm
sure they're trying to but she's just a
she's a regular republican conservative
who is a conservative and is not a big
squish they they try to tie her in with
all sorts of kooky things on the
internet
they said that she has posted about q
anon they said when asked about q anon
ms flores denied ever having supported
the conspiracy theory which claims that
a group of satan worshipping elites who
run a child sex ring is trying to
control the government and the media
where would she ever get a crazy idea
like that you know where would she it
would be so hard to get a crazy idea
like that because all of jeffrey
epstein's black books are under lock and
key by the governments
all the ones that talk about the most
powerful people in the world going and
having sex with children on his
james bond villain private island yeah
it's so weird i don't know where she
would have gotten an idea like that but
she doesn't even support that idea
she doesn't even support that so she's
she is going to be the far right extreme
she's hitler
and desantis is hitler
and trump was hitler and everybody's
hitler
everybody they're a grave threat to our
sacred democracy except for blm when
they burn the country down that's
totally fine except for antifa except
for chuck schumer when he says we're
coming for you cavanaugh and then
someone goes and tries to assassinate
him and yeah except for that's that's
not a threat to our sacred democracy
what the what the conservatives are
doing that is
that is all of this to say
all of this to say
fortune favors the bold it ties right
back in with the boris johnson point
fortune favors the bold here i'm not
saying you got to be reckless i'm not
saying you need to be some eccentric
total kook or crank
but
right now the democrats are underwater
on everything democrat policies are
failing
ordinary americans not just republicans
but people in the middle old school
liberals people who are not very
political are disgusted by what the
democrats are doing they are supporting
abortion up until the moment of birth
sometimes after birth they support
transiting little kids and taking them
to drag bars and strip clubs they are
destroying the value of your dollar
they're making it very difficult to fill
up your gas tank and feed your family
they've led they have allowed the first
major war in europe since world war ii
to take place
they've allowed a flood of record
numbers of illegal aliens the list goes
on and on and on
if you want to win
what do you think is going to be a more
successful strategy
pointing out that everything they touch
turns to ash and you're going to offer a
clear alternative a choice not an echo
and you're going to run on that or
trying to be a really nice guy and say
joe joe biden's actually not that bad
he's actually a genuinely good man
that's what mitt romney said the other
day the squish extraordinaire mitt
romney said you know look trump he's
really bad he wrote an essay on july 4th
in the atlantic liberal essay in a
liberal publication on july 4 on the 4th
of july by a nominally republican
senator saying that trump is evil and
joe biden's a genuinely good man i don't
think joe biden's a genuinely good man i
think he's a nasty nasty fellow i think
you can see
the marks of his awful character
anywhere you look up to and including
most recently the fact that he refuses
to acknowledge one of his own
grandchildren who's living under under
threats at the moment he won't even
acknowledge who she is but there's so
many other knocks on the man's personal
character he says no he's a genuinely
good man
it's not true and second of all do you
really think in a year where the
democrats are so extremely unpopular
you're going to win by saying actually
those people who are screwing up your
lives they're not so bad
we should we should kind of meet in the
middle don't you think don't you think i
don't think so i don't think that's a
good idea i think it's going to work
there's really really
bad stuff coming out of the democrat
party right now especially
the new york times mentions the
satan worshiping pedophile ring the pedo
stuff has gotten
it's it's become undeniable from the
left washington state right now
washington state school board director
is offering sex ed classes at her sex
shop a director of the school board owns
a sex shop and she's offering sex ed
classes not just on the birds and the
bees and how babies are made but on
sexual pleasure on pleasuring yourself
to nine-year-olds
to nine-year-olds her name is jen mason
she was the former school board
president she's a sex educator and owner
of wink wink in bellingham she is
offering
at her identity inclusive sex shop
classes for kids as young as nine that
deal with quote sexual anatomy for
pleasure and reproduction and quote
safer sex practices for all kinds of
sexual activities this after in the same
town
last year in a first grade class a
teacher decided to teach her
six-year-old students about the values
of transgenderism and read the book i am
jazz which is a book about a
two-year-old tran transgender
baby a baby two years old who's a boy
who identifies as a girl
it's it's not even just in portland or
san francisco or los angeles or
greenwich village or anything like that
even in ostensibly conservative places
you are seeing the left push a deviant
radical
pedophilic call it what it is pedo
sexual agenda you're even seeing this
kind of stuff
in nashville
which we'll get to in one second first
though in the last week the left tried
to cancel both the fourth of july and
our newest daily wire plus team member
jordan peterson on both fronts they
failed harder than joe biden on a
bicycle that's not nice who writes this
copy that's not nice because no matter
how much twitter blue checks complain
independence day burgers and fireworks
they're not going anywhere and neither
is jordan peterson nowhere he's not
going anywhere baby his new series
dragons monsters and men is out right
now exclusively on daily wire plus it's
being met with rave reviews it is jordan
like you've never seen him before take a
look
one of the things i tell young men well
on young women as well but the young men
really need to hear this more i think
you should be a monster an absolute
monster and then you should learn how to
control it
so a man who's capable of aggression but
has it under control is a way more
useful man than
one who cannot do that and so you're
willing to go get a job but you're
terrified of an interview it's like
there's a dragon for you because you
want to fight the dragons that guard the
gates of the treasure that you wish to
attain
the productivity
requires aim orientation responsibility
discipline that willingness to work that
willingness to make sacrifices which is
the hallmark of maturity in the service
of a higher goal
it orients you solidly in the world if
you do that and it gives you a dragon to
fight
what do you want to grow up you want to
be illiterate
you want to be inarticulate
you're going to have to negotiate
you're going to have to lead you're
going to have to convince
you're going to have to think to say to
a 18 year old you're okay the way you
are
that just deflates them
[Music]
you know when you go to the gym and you
start lifting weights well your body's
going to transform but it's not going to
do that if you just sit around you have
to face your being with the necessity of
transformation and then all sorts of new
things that you had no idea you were
capable of will make themselves manifest
those are the dragons you know the ones
that stand in the path that leads to the
light
and you have to say to yourself
i will
do good
nonetheless
everyone great makes that decision
make that decision because maybe you're
great
[Music]
in his four-part series jordan gives
sage advice for embracing and improving
upon one's nature to achieve greatness
you can become a member by going to
dailywireplus.com
right now you get 35 off your new
membership help us build the future that
you want to see
dailywireplus.com check out jordan
peterson's new show
we'll be right back with a lot more
just when you think it is safe to go
back in the water that is turning the
frickin frogs gay you find out no the
problems are occurring here as well i
thought when i left l.a i'd leave all
the crazy radical bizarre sexual
consistently pedo
left-wing politics behind
no no no more drag queen story hours and
deviants twerking for five-year-olds
well
you get to
nashville even nashville i love
nashville i love tennessee i'm so glad i
moved here it's great but these crazy
radicals
follow you they're going everywhere
they're really targeting actually
left-wing places i just got a tip
yesterday from the nashville pamphleteer
which is a conservative paper in
nashville
the bell court theater which is an indie
bougie film center here in nashville
is hosting someone
to kick off their their queer cinema
series his name is alak vaid manon i
don't know if that's his real name or
some invented thing he is a transvestite
he's a hulking dude who wears dresses
and all sorts of crazy clothing that's
that's not even the big problem here the
big problem is he said really disturbing
things about little kids and sex so this
guy alak vaid manon
has said quote i believe in the radical
notion that little girls are complicated
people there are no fairy tales and no
princesses here
little girls are trans
queer
kinky
devious
kind mean beautiful ugly tremendous
and peculiar
your kids aren't as straight and narrow
as you think they are like everybody
else i've been a cute little girl
it it just gets creepier and it just
gets creepier and then you get to that
i've been a cute little girl this
hulking hairy dude wearing a dress
talking about how little girls little
tiny girls are actually kinky and
devious
defending men going into the girls
bathrooms
saying all this transgender the the
fears of transgender
politics it's totally made up who it's
totally fine if grown husky men go in
and go into the girls locker room and
change in front of your girls they're
not perverts they're not oh by the way
little girls are kinky according to him
why is
the bell court theater
in nashville
hosting a sexual deviant who describes
little girls as kinky
and it's he says little girls can be
mean
that's true he says little girls can be
tremendous yeah sure
little girls can be devious and kinky
and queer
says this
deviant who believes that he is a little
girl you you hear this by the way from
convicted pedos a lot
these sorts of things where they'll say
no i'm i'm just like these little kids
i'm just like these little girls i'm
just like it's so disturbing
and this guy is being invited to host a
public event
at the movies we shouldn't have that
this guy should be getting treatment for
his obvious psychiatric diseases this
guy should not be allowed
within 300 yards of little kids
this guy
we should not
as a society tolerate this anywhere and
we certainly should not do that in a
conservative place
nashville itself is two to one democrat
but the democrats here they're generally
very nice they're generally reasonable
it's a very very red state here in
tennessee
we do not need to tolerate this
we can just say no
and if you
are a member of the bell court theater
if you live near the belkworth i would
call them and tell them to disinvite
this guy this guy should not be
encouraged
to to do these sorts of things he should
be
treated with the compassion he needs
which is to
go get treatment and be kept away from
society until he gets a little bit
better
we don't we don't need to
come to into the middle on this step we
don't need to reconcile we don't need to
be really nice squishy conciliatory
republicans and say well you know look
i don't i don't think three-year-old
girls are kinky only eight-year-old
girls are whatever
listen i don't think that men should be
twerking for kids at the public library
maybe they can just shimmy and jiggle no
there's no meeting in the middle here
man there's no there's no splitting the
baby it's just wrong it's disgusting we
all know it's wrong and disgusting we
don't need to tolerate it keep these
people out of the public and keep them
away from kids all right it's not it's
not that complicated and there's no
first amendment protection for this
weirdo
to go present queer cinema month and
talk about kinky little girls okay don't
have to do it
the wind is at our sails
the political winds are against these
people and the party that welcomes them
the democrat party
take the advantage press the advantage
don't give an inch republicans are
feeling emboldened right now there was
an ad that went viral yesterday uh this
is from a guy jerome davidson who's
running for congress in arizona
take a
listen
democrats like to say that no one needs
an ar-15 for self-defense
that no one could possibly need all 30
rounds
but when this rifle is the only thing
standing between your family
[Music]
and a dozen angry democrats in clan
hoods
you just might need that semi-automatic
in all 30 rounds
[Music]
this is a really clever ad and it's it's
a clever ad
not just for the reasons that everyone
is talking about it's red meat yeah you
go get them you go yeah that's right
this is we're defending guns we're
calling democrats racist yeah baby this
is great it's not it's not just clever
for that reason
frankly i actually think the whole
democrats are the real racist line is a
little bit overused and the constant
hearkening back to the antebellum south
and and referring to the democrats as
the party of the clan
sure it's true democrats are the party
of the clan but it it seems a little
cheap to me and here's why it seems
cheap to me
and it's actually why this ad is so
clever and it's why the ku klux klan is
a safe subject for this ad
the ku klux klan doesn't exist
practically speaking there is no such
thing as the ku klux klan there have
been multiple groups in u.s history that
have called themselves the ku klux klan
none of which exist today it's gone it's
a boogie man it's not real
when you fear political violence in your
community or anywhere else in the
country
do you think it's going to come from the
ku klux klan from people wearing hoods
no of course not it'll it's going to
come from the left almost certainly but
it's going to come from antifa or it's
going to come from blm or it's going to
come from other left it's going to come
from ruth sent us or the other
anti-anti-pro-life groups anti-pro-life
pro-abortion groups it's gonna it's
gonna come from left-wing militants but
it's
it's not the clan
the reason this is such a clever ad is
that everybody hates the clan
it's a it's a totally unifying symbol
it's a symbol of an evil that isn't even
real anymore it does of a boogeyman so
people can unite around that it does
draw the historical connection between
the democrat party and the ku klux klan
it does point out that second amendment
is not is not some uh
buttress of white supremacy in the and
the patriarchy and the republicans and
the conservatives no actually
vulnerable people minority groups or
women who are physically more vulnerable
than men they actually benefit much more
from the second amendment because it's
an equalizer
against mob against angry mobs that
might show up to your house or against
people who are physically bigger and
stronger than you so it's clever for
that reason it's a reminder too
of something that i've said for a year i
think this is the proof of something
that i've said for years now which is
that today in america
our public discourse has become so
shallow that the the only way we can
talk about evil is as racism racism is
the not only the the greatest evil in
the country it's really the only evil
and so when we want to really attack
it's the worst thing you can be called
in america is to be called a racist and
so whenever we want to attack someone if
you really want to hit them you call
them a racist even when what they're
doing has nothing to do with race
republican democrats will accuse
republicans of racism for wanting to cut
taxes or wanting to reform schools or
wanting to save black babies when we
overrule roe v wade and we make it more
different past pro-life laws and make it
more difficult to have abortions that
will disproportionately save black lives
it will increase the black and hispanic
portions of the population and somehow
the libs call that racist as well it's
the only way that we can view things and
the only way that we can view the
struggle between good and evil in
american history is through the lens of
the civil rights movement and that has
been true for a long time chris caldwell
wrote a very good book to this effect a
few years ago called the age of
entitlement after the civil rights act
and after the great society uh that
represented
not merely some new law that was being
passed but it represented a kind of
revolution in america and in the way
that we think of ourselves and so what's
so brilliant about this ad is that
jerome davidson is plugging into that
he's saying look this is what is going
to resonate
this is how americans view themselves so
i am going to put myself there it's the
same reason that candidates wave flags
wave the flag wrap yourself in the flag
is because we know that those symbols
resonate with people and in america
today
for everybody
the ku klux klan
is
one of one of if not the highest
representations of evil racism is evil
the two are synonymous and civil rights
is the struggle it is the struggle for
for
liberation
now speaking of civil rights everyone's
trying to apply
the black civil rights movement to their
own groups this was a strategy
undertaken by the left during the 1970s
they saw how effective civil rights was
for black people
he said okay we're going to use this for
hispanic people
we're going to use this for asian people
we're going to use this for women second
wave feminism
it never made any sense these black
people actually are a unique
circumstance in america the fact that
lots and lots of black people the
majority of black people who are in
america have some dissent from slavery
and that their ancestors brought over in
chains is different than any other group
hispanics can claim oppression the
italians and the irish i guess can claim
oppression the asians can claim
oppression but those groups chose to
come to america and for black people
it's different so it gives black people
and
i mean obviously they're black
immigrants from africa who came after
slavery but for black people as a group
that creates a unique historical
circumstance and groups like the ford
foundation and other left-wing
institutions decided they were going to
blur those distinctions and try to apply
the the ethos of civil rights to all of
these other groups and it worked pretty
well now even to the point that we're
talking about the civil rights against
oppression for
homosexuals or transgender as though
it's the same thing as breaking free
from chattel slavery and jim crow
it's the same thing now as breaking free
from your bounds of biology and
and dresses and stiletto heels so
buzzfeed you you understand that the
ellen page saga that has dominated our
public discourse for the past few days
the idea that ellen page this actress
now goes by the name elliot and doesn't
want to be called ellen anymore this
created a big stir on twitter because
now if you sit call ellen page ellen you
can be booted off it happened to jordan
peterson it happened to dave rubin for
even reporting on jordan peterson well
buzzfeed then came back and said wait
wait a second twitter you violated your
own rules against hate speech because in
your trending topics bar you used the
phrase helen helen ellen page because
people were talking about ellen page
ellen page trended but according to your
own rules ellen page can't trend because
that name this actress's name is hate
speech because the actress doesn't want
to go by ellen anymore and then do you
know what twitter did because we're
living all the way through the looking
glass in clown world
twitter apologized and said you're right
we can't we can't allow
a woman's name to trend that woman's
name
is hate speech
what does this represent if ellen page
tomorrow
came out and said hey i'm ellen again
do you know what you know what's so
crazy
they would have to get rid of elliot
because elliot would then become her
dead name they call it a dead name when
a person decides to pretend to be a
member of the opposite sex and change
his name and then the name that that
person had gone by for his entire life
goes away and you're not allowed to even
utter it anymore that's that's pretty
crazy right especially because they
could change the name back and then it's
the other one that goes away
what this represents is something much
bigger than transgenderism or even
sexual politics it represents
the left's broader rejection of the past
everything that came before is evil and
awful and oppressive we need to liberate
ourselves from the past
past is always evil the president is
always a crisis in the future is always
going to be a utopia just so long as you
give us a little bit more power that's
the pitch that the left makes and you
see it so clearly in the the idea of
dead naming even one's own personal past
even one's own
past identity
can no longer be acknowledged it's not
just tearing down statues
of old dead people it's not just even
rewriting the history books it's your
own past that now has to be completely
denied in what is a kind of
pseudo-religious sacrament in
christianity you have baptism where the
old the old man is washed away and you
and you now put on the garment of christ
and you have a new life in christ well
that's what you have in a perverse way
in a sacrilegious way through the
transgender coming out you cast off your
old name you cast off your old identity
and that is dead now and now you have
this new identity in sexual delusion it
runs really really deep it touches on
all of the bizarre
perverse eccentricities of leftism it
goes a lot deeper than just some actress
it's really weird i think it's turning a
lot of people off i think people are
waking up to how bizarre not just this
weird sexual ideology is but the entire
leftist agenda the wind is at our sales
i hope that ellen and elliot and all the
pages and all this weird and the bell
court theater and all this craziness i
hope it continues to trend all the way
to november press the advantage the wind
is at our sails i'm michael knowles this
is the michael nola show see you
tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bori supervising producer mathis glover
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer danny d'amico
associate producer justine turley audio
mixer mike coromina and hair and makeup
by cherokee heart michael knowles show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 2022 today on the ben shapiro
show democrats begin openly talking
about dumping joe biden in favor of
other candidates the media are out to
police misinformation while still
purveying it and we meet some new fresh
democratic faces making waves that's
today on the bench bureau show give it a
listen